Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god, fucking... my internet's back.
Yay!
Oh my god, I have so many things to update you guys about because so many things happened in the last couple of days since my internet was out.
First of all, um, as you guys all know, uh, or maybe you don't, or you don't follow me on Twitter, uh, which is understandable, it is Twitter.
Mint and I will be doing a 3D concert!
Yay!
It's gonna be our, uh, revenge concert, because the last time it was pretty scuffed.
So, um, um, OshiSparks, let me, let me put up, I'm sorry, it's, it's been a while.
I know, like, it's been, like, two days, but I already feel so unprofessional.
I already lost my, like, how do you do anything anymore?
Whenever I don't stream for a while, I'm just like, how do I, how do I be a streamer again?
Anyway, so the biggest update, yes, on December 14th in Atlanta, uh, Mint and I will be doing a 3D concert.
Yes, full 3D.
It's not chibi models, guys.
It's full 3D.
Um, and I want to say a huge thank you to, uh, OshiSpark for the, giving us, like, a proposal.
They reached out to us asking us if, you know, if they could, like, um, um, organize the whole thing.
And, uh, because, like, we talked, like, you know, we were tweeting about wanting to do a revenge concert, and they actually reached out to us.
This is a plan has been, like, a lot, like, to be fair, it's not like this has been planned for a long time.
If I'm, like, very truthfully honest with you guys, this was not planned for a long time.
Like, this 3D concert, um, it just, everything just happened to line up.
Like, uh, they reached out to us, like, I think, like, um, a month or two ago about it, and then everything just happened to line up.
Um, so yeah, I'm really excited.
They are, uh, they are going to, uh, be handling majority of the organization for this, like, vent booking event.
Venue-wise, like, so we don't have to worry about the venue.
Venue, merch, tickets, um, everything.
Unfortunately, um, there won't be any streaming tickets because of music licensing.
Um, as y'all know, music rights is, like, really... music rights is really difficult to get and everything in terms of, like, what you think we can do with the songs after, like, for the concerts and everything.
But, um, I asked the organizers, um, also, yeah, they're handling the, you know, motion capture and everything.
So, um, huge shout out to Oshie Sparks for handling all of that for us.
Um, um, another thing is that, uh, because we don't have streaming tickets, um, I specifically requested that, uh, I would like to have clips of, like, some of our favorite performances.
Like, uh, each of us, like, Mint and I, we both get to pick one performance that, uh, we like the most from this concert and upload it onto our channels.
Um, and from the music licensing rights, we are allowed to do that.
So, yay!
We just can't stream it.
But we are allowed to post a clip of any of the performances that we do, just one for each of us on our own channels.
So for those who can't make it, uh, we will have that up on our own channels after the concert.
I don't know when exactly it'll be posted, um, but that's something we can do for you guys.
Anyway, um, I highly recommend joining the members, um, because, uh, we will have early bird ticket pre-sells, um, for the members.
So if you are a, uh, it says on the website, so you can see on the Phantom Thief website.
By the way, the name was decided by the organizers.
They're like, can we call it Phantom Thief Revenge?
And then Mint and I were like, yeah, go for it.
We were like, yeah, why not?
So it was actually, uh, the organizers' idea to, like, name it that.
And we're just like, yeah, go for it.
Like, oh, we don't care.
Like, that's a great name.
Um, um, but yeah, um, so if you are a member, I did make a community post, um, and you just basically need to sign in.
As long as you're a member on either me or Mint, uh, there is a chance for you to get a, um, the pre-sell tickets, uh, for, for the concert.
Um, so yeah, for all the members out there, um, make sure to check the community post for all the details and everything.
Um, I'm trying to remember what else was in the contract.
I'm like, what else do I need to say again?
Guys, I'm very good at shilling stuff.
If you guys didn't know, number one shill here.
Um, anyway, um, but yes, uh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So excited for your first 3D concert.
I know.
I'm really excited because like, um, one of the things I've really, I really wanted, I, I, I, oh my gosh, I really, really wanted to do a 3D concert one day, but like, I never thought like, you know, it'd be something with a venue and stuff, like with actual people going there.
Um, because you know, no one really knows me as like, um, as like the, the singer of the groups of like, or just the singer in general.
Um, but like it has, actually is one of my dreams and one of my goals to be able to, to be able to do that creation.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for shilling.
Doki, here's the payment.
Guys, this is one of the organizers by the way.
Did I do good creation?
Did I, did, did I do good?
Anyway, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, zero, thank you for the 10 gifted shifts.
Um, yeah, he's one of the organizers, uh, you know, she's um, but yes, like I said, huge shout out to Oshie Spark for handling everything regarding this.
Um, because like Min and I, we were planning something for it, but then Oshie Spark approached us and we're like, oh my God, this is better.
Cause then let's work for us.
You're like, oh, that's, thank God.
Let's work.
You guys can handle it.
We'll, we'll show up.
Um, uh, Rocket, thank you for the five gifted shifts.
Thank you.
Um, what else?
Oh my gosh, I lost my train of thought.
What was it?
What did I want to say guys?
I already lost my train of thought.
Um, what, uh, oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Regarding dancing and singing because the last time I actually took a lot of dance classes, um, last time.
And like, obviously I wasn't able to show the dance classes.
So now I'm like, oh my God, I gotta do that again.
I gotta go back to dance classes again.
So, um, so I'm really excited.
Uh, I'm really excited.
We have like special choreo, um, for like our, the songs that we're doing and everything.
So I hope you guys are super excited.
Um, and even though like, um, even though like for those who aren't able to be there for the concert, um, I am planning on an actual full 3D debut in the future.
Um, and, uh, I'm really, oh my gosh, it's like, I have a lot of stuff in my head, um, because I've been planning this.
I feel like I've been planning a 3D debut for like a year now, like a year and a half now, but it's very ambitious.
So like now I'm like, all right, back on to back to the beginning.
So, so, um, we're doing it again.
So I hope you guys look forward to like the official 3D debut.
Um, when it does happen, it's not like after the concert, I'll just be like surprised.
I'm just going to use my 3D model now.
Um, I'm still planning something incredibly special for it.
Um, and it's going to be on stream, um, when the official 3D debut, like on stream and everything.
Um, and, but it's just, it just takes a while, you know, everything just lined up, um, with the concert.
And I feel like it was such a amazing opportunity and I don't rush my, I don't want to rush my official 3D debut.
So like the 3D concert was such an amazing opportunity to have.
Um, and it's with Mint as well.
Like I wouldn't want to do this with anybody else regarding this concert because she can carry my ass.
Like she has the most experience when it comes to like idol and concerts and stuff.
So like, if not, if anything, she can carry my fucking ass throughout it.
So I thought it was like, you know, the perfect occasion.
Um, it's really like, even though this would technically be the debut for our 3Ds, um, sorry, I'm still coughing.
It's really hard to say no to this opportunity.
And, um, and we will try our best, uh, we'll try our best to make sure that those who can make it will still be able to, uh, will still be able to see like photos and like clips of it.
And like I said, Mint and I will be uploading individual uploads on each of our channel.
Um, and each of our channels.
So those who did miss it will be able to see like one of the performances and stuff.
Uh, but yes, tickets go on sale on Thursday.
Uh, check out phantomthief.com.
Um, all I'm saying is that for the VIP packages, Mint and I will be together signing the autographs for the VIP packages.
So I don't know.
I mean, it's pretty hype.
Cucumber, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mental carry.
I'm not gonna read the last one.
Karisha, did I do good?
Did I shill it okay?
Did I do okay, Karisha?
Anyway, um, another update.
Uh, another update.
Um, um, dad's not here.
Uh, because like I said, my internet was out.
Um, and also like there was a flood.
So the reason why the internet was out was because, uh, there was a flood that sort of like destroyed the internet.
So, so our entire, we never, we, our entire building had no internet and the roads were sort of like low-key flooded and everything was wet.
So then I was like, I called up a dog sitter and was like, can you, can you look after, can you look after dad for me?
And then she was like, yeah, it's a new dog sitter because the other one was like not available.
And I was like texting, I was like messaging people like emergency, I need a dog sitter right now.
Um, anyway, um, this is the photo they sent me of, this, this was the photo they sent me.
You're next.
You're next dad.
Um, I just thought it was really funny.
He, he saw his future.
Don't never forget.
This is what happens.
Doki Amberdome.
He looks so concerned.
He's just like, is that me?
Is that me?
Mom?
You must be, your ass must be really heavy.
That said so excited to see your full 3D.
Thank you, thank you for the superchat, thank you.
Alex, thank you for the superchat, thank you.
And also nexi, thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
So excited to see you both in 3D at the concert.
I'll be there for sure.
Gonna do my best to get the VIP, thank you, thank you for Thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah, you guys gotta compete against the wisp for those tickets to Good luck who's also apparently was called waffle house is nearby the venue as well I saw I saw the photos of the venue.
It looks so cool.
Wait, they sent us the photos of the venue and Wait, let me see.
I could find it and if I have so many guys, by the way I have so many discord groups like it's so hard to find anything anymore And they're all like not named you're just like it's just all like names of the people in the discord group But there's so I just have too many.
I just there's just so many I need to show you guys the venue It looks really sick.
I okay.
This is a photo.
They sent us of the venue And it looks really really nice Give me a sec
Okay So this is the venue for Where the concert's gonna be I thought it was really cool like oh my god.
Look this is where we're gonna be performing This is it.
I'm so excited.
I'm really excited for My dance class.
Well, yeah, I am.
I'm low-key.
I'm very excited for my dance classes and my singing classes because That means like, you know, I can give you guys a better performance I think in the end, I'm pretty sure like, um I'm gonna be spending a lot of my money that I'm getting from this concert into my desk
You guys waited so long you waited so long to see me dance and sing and I Really want to like make sure you guys have like a really good time And that you you guys have like a lot of fun watching and have like actual choreo and everything But yeah, I'm very excited.
I'm just really happy that you guys can actually get to experience it for once It's been like, you know many years in the making And yes And even though you can't go to the concert you guys can you know We'll have clips of it uploaded onto our channel.
So you guys don't miss out And obviously and after this in the future, I would love to do more like online Concerts too for you guys in the future because like that basically unlocks it unlocks that potential after that All right, so that's the that's the concert update Other life updates.
Let me say I wrote a list cuz a lot of shit happened.
Also like I need to talk to you guys I know like we have goodnight dragoons, but like I want to say it's okay.
I Okay, I need to say I'm gonna say this.
I fucking I hate the bank.
Oh my god.
I oh Okay, so I need to rant this out loud before like I know it's been 22 minutes and we still haven't played the game yet But like I really need to talk about this, but I fucking hate the bank here I oh I hate Canadian banks so fucking much.
Yes.
I have no idea Oh, okay So like I got my business access card and then I also got my pin number and everything in the mail But then the thing so I didn't I want to get online banking So I called this phone and I cuz it was like, you know, I got my power back So I was like,
oh I should register for online banking And then apparently you can't register online right now for some reason it's down so then I got my I got my internet pack and power back and then it was like, oh, um, oh Hey, by the way They were like by the way It's 1 a.m.
By the way internet came back at like 1 to 2 a.m.
And I was like, oh, hey, hey, so
I Won't register for online banking and stuff and then by the way, they're like, okay we're gonna put you on hold and then it was like they put me on hold for like 45 minutes cuz I was like, you know what?
I'm I can finally get work done.
I Can finally get work done now that my intern it's back so I waited 45 minutes and then they're like Good morning.
We're here to open up your online bank.
And I was like, yes I didn't receive anything regarding my online bank stuff.
And then they're like, oh your account seems to be a business account Unfortunately business account services aren't open yet.
It's they're closed so you gotta wait until the morning to call them back and then I was like
I Can't do work while I'm like on hold because my office has no Reception like it has like one bar of reception reception because it's secluded.
It's like there's like walls everywhere It's secluded area because I didn't want like neighbors to complain and stuff So I chose this place as the office room and I had to go out of the office room To my bedroom to make that call so I had to wait 45 minutes of doing nothing And then just to be like,
sorry You got the call back in the morning because our business our business account services are not available And then I was like, okay, so this morning I called this morning I called the I called the bank and then they were like, oh, hey.
Hello.
This is the business services What can we do for you?
And I was like, hey, I want to open online banking cuz like I didn't receive like a password for it and Then they were like, oh Well, I'm more unfortunately you have to do that at your local branch I was like
What and by the way, I by the way Flashback to like a month ago when I was at my local branch.
I didn't have my card yet I didn't have my access card yet.
And I was like, hey, so I'm waiting for my access card right now I really want to open my online bank account.
So can I open my online bank account?
And then that Fucking big teller was like, sorry You have you can do that, but when you get your card you can do that on the phone yourself You don't have to do that at the branch.
I was like, okay, so it was that Fucker that guy hates.
Oh It all leads back to him Back to this fucker.
I hope he he knows he I hope he looked up my business.
I hope he looked up my business so he can watch this VOD So he knows how much I hate him
He knows the name of this I hope you look up this VOD so, you know, I hate you so much I The amount of times you've wasted for me.
Oh my god
Was like This is one month the one month of conning me and it all leads back to him This this one he fucking structured this this for one month and it all leads back to him It all he told me I could do that by the phone and I kept thinking.
Oh great I could do it by the phone, but in the end I go to my local fucking
So, yeah anyway, so that's really That's really all I wanted to complain about because I I just I hate my local branch guys But it's literally the closest one the next like the next local The next local bank that's closest to me is like It's like a 20-minute walk and like I guys the closest to me was a 10-minute walk I don't want to walk another I don't want to walk another 20 minutes guys.
I can't
Do this is the worst part And Yes, like why don't you guys?
Okay, so also because there was a flooding issue Apparently, okay.
So there's a lot of parking lots at my building and like the lowest parking lot The lowest parking lot apparently was very flooded like it was like really Really bad Like it was like Like the car like the water hit halfway to the car.
That's how flooded I didn't go downstairs But people were like talking about it.
I was like, oh my god.
Thank God.
I don't have a car
It was literally like halfway to the car at that point and like yeah, it was bad it was that bad Fucking bad
But yes, I don't have a car so that's great Anyway, I have a lot of updates, but I'm gonna keep most majority of the update stuff.
Okay, let me see I have like lots of more.
Let me see if I wrote them down Oh, yeah, I need to write this down show the the show this and show Uh, okay, I'll be showing this at goodnight dragons Later, um, cuz I need to keep make sure I have enough yapping for you guys That's been almost 30 minutes of yapping guys,
I'm sorry I'm I was so behind when you know when the internet was out.
I was so fucking behind with everything So like the moment I guys I have a confession to make I did go to the internet cafe I I have a confession to make you know how I said, I wasn't gonna go to an internet cafe I like 11 p.m.
I went to the internet cafe at 11 p.m.
Guys.
No, no, you don't understand You don't understand like I was I had a lot of work to do guys.
No, you don't understand I stayed there till 4 in the morning.
I Stayed there guys.
No, I do not have a problem.
First off.
I do not have a problem Second off.
I swear if I go one more day off the internet.
I'm gonna fucking lose it.
But third off I don't have a
Don't have a problem Look, I even stayed in the lobby I even stayed in the in the apartment lobby because the apartment lobby had Wi-Fi So like I didn't had like free Wi-Fi A lot of people were just downstairs in the apartment lobby using the internet so if I so I can't have a problem if the rest of the people that live in my apartment building also did that so
So if they did that then like then you're trying to say they have a problem too, but we don't anyway But yes, I did go to the internet cafe to catch up on a lot of work Anyway We are gonna be playing backyard baseball 97 I'm super excited to Play this game.
I can't believe they finally actually reported this on the steam slash PC Because look I might have played like one game of deadlock, but that was okay.
That was it Okay, it might have been two games of deadlock and I realized I wasted my time because that was like two hours of deadlock Because I bought like three hours of credit and I realized I only had one hour left to work But so then I bought two more hours of credit.
So that's why I stay there until 4 in the morning But I did get work done
Anyway, anyway As I was saying, so I'm very excited to play backyard baseball 97 because like this was actually a game I played a lot when I was a little bird I didn't know what I was doing because I refused to read at that time, which I got better at Better at refusing to read by the way But like I just thought it was like I just thought I could tell it was fun I just didn't know what I was doing because I didn't understand any of the mechanics because it's all about It was all it's all about like it's like basically question like that equation game where like you're Managing players and stuff like that and then trying to take them to the major league baseball team for kids So yeah,
anyway, um The only reason I know about Shohei Otani is because apparently his like 50th home run sold for like How many thousands of 500,000 I don't even know his but I just knew about it cuz like I just saw on Twitter how his baseball sold for a lot Of money and I was like and then that he did and that he I think like the reason The Dodgers had the hololive collab together.
It was because like it was also for his birthday I believe was that it?
I don't know.
I could be spreading misinformation but we all know I
I could be spreading misinformation, but
It was okay I was not and I knew about him because of the fact that it's it was like his birthday and then they did the hololive collab and And I thought that was really cool that they did it for his birthday because that means he's like he likes VTubers and I thought that was funny and cool at the same time Cuz then it's like oh my god,
even see see normies like VTubers too.
Like we're hitting mainstream, baby Well, obviously we like VTubers in Japan are mainstream, but we're hitting mainstream in NA
But that but yeah like his 50th home run sold for like two million dollars and like I I was like damn That's a lot of fucking money.
And then that's how I know about Shohei Hotani.
Anyway, we're gonna make the next one guys in 97 obviously We're gonna make the next one in 97, let's fucking go Let's see, I don't know Oh sound guy is here.
That's great.
Okay.
Oh my god the classic Hey batter batter batter.
Also, I have my managing glasses on.
Oh, you guys can't see the game Yeah, wait, why is the game showing up?
Oh my god, is it one of those things where it's like it capped?
Oh my god, I swear to God I think it's like I think it captures It captured it's it's oh it's not a game capture.
Okay.
It's not a game capture guys.
So that's fine All right.
Let's see Sis wait, oh, I'm not charging my My phone is also not charging right now.
Is it charging now?
Oh it is.
Okay Sorry, I'm a little bit of a mess right now.
But when am I not?
When am I not a mess though to be fair There you go, I gotta make sure it's not it's not It's not screen capture, so it's not a game capture so I have to do a screen capture A window capture.
All right.
Here you go the classic intro
My god, this is a oh my god, this is so nostalgia.
Holy shit
This is actually just gonna be us guys right here ultra grand championship of the universe This is gonna be us That's gonna be it.
We're gonna be up there dragons all of us.
Oh Okay, how do I?
Okay, we play coaches.
Okay All right Dude wait, where is it?
Okay.
There you go How long can I make the name?
Jokey Wait real wait, no in honor of real jokey bird By the way, the reason why real jokey bird was like bottom frag in game two and three was because after the first game they felt really bad that they were Fucking demolish.
Oh my god shit that they were Demolishing the other team because they were supposed to be a sub that they Unbinded paper form and also turned on mouse acceleration.
So
If you were a real jokey bird if you're a real jokey bird you would you would make sure like even though you know We were gonna get DQ'd anyway, because like hat like basically we legitimately had like two players that were from the original team Everybody else were substitutes.
So like so like they were so like they got they so they were like We had to get disqualified because like the whole team wasn't there which is Understandable because half the like all the substitutes the substitutes of this Tronova tournament were like Actual players that's been playing the fucking game since like it since it since it first came out in CN servers so like obviously they're fucking good And we had three of them So then so then the bot so then he was like,
okay I'm gonna unbind a paper form and turn on mouse acceleration So they were like so they could make it more fair.
I was like how fucking dare we were gonna get DQ'd anyway, like Might as well just break their spirit
If you were if you were a real jokey bird you would do you wouldn't care just break their spirit All right, there you go create team real dokey.
All right, obviously we should be Where's yellow?
We should be yellow We should be is there like Vicious, what is us?
What what would we fucking be?
Okay, super duper White green little mighty super duper.
Okay, we should be humongous because that's like the Biggest it can be.
Oh my god.
Wait, fuck.
There's nothing.
That's like the Dodgers we could
What what is the closest to the Dodgers guys we got wait, okay, so then what's the closest to the Dodgers?
We might as well actually make the next Tiny we might as well make the next one Like
Okay, okay Humongous rockets is that really that's the Dodgers, right?
Hey, we gotta get the blue in to that.
All right.
There you go.
We're like copyright free.
We're copyright free Dodge
Okay, this is it we're going all in this is our team now All right It's high True all right.
This is it.
This is we're basically the Dodgers pick teams.
I know wait All right.
I know what wait rocket.
Is that us?
That's not me The fuck.
Okay.
Wait, where is he?
Who is he?
Everybody told me to get that got them Pablo Pablo Pablo, oh my god Pablo The fuck is that My goat Pablo Nicknamed secret weapon 818 Pablo does not speak any English it seems but he knows the language of baseball and knows it Well simply put Jesus what the bro?
He's perfect.
Yes What if I would not pick Pablo, oh my god, that's good.
We got Pablo.
All right, the rest of you can leave now
You guys can all leave we already have Pablo you can be everybody Pablo the goat he's my man Okay, he's good at feeling Ernie funny bones.
Everyone loves Ernie because he's so silly and a good ball player to a great catching and a decent arm Ernie is a great choice for second or third base.
Okay, that's okay.
Oh my gosh.
Who do we get?
We need some but we got we got our all-rounder Kenny.
Who the fuck is Kenny?
Is this Kenny?
I can play.
Oh my wait.
Wait, we're cheating.
He has wheels He actually he actually has wheels he
Guilty thank you for the aqua soup, but thank you.
Thank you ready ride the humongous Rockets to the world
Thank you, oh my god, bro Like wheels like that's why we invent guys.
This is why we invented the wheel a wheel is faster than running.
That's literally cheating We're letting him it's like driving a we're like driving the car to the next base.
Oh my He's so fast look at him like, okay, why is this not four balls?
Speed like what are you not for balls?
You have a little car as you do Hot wheels All right.
Let's see.
Don't let the wheelchair fool you Kenny is a fantastic boy at the wheelchair.
It's the reason why I'm picking Kenny He's a sure-handed outfielder and a speedy base wheeler, all right, you're in the team you're in Kenny You're in all right, I think we can honestly if I could I'll just make the team Kenny and Pablo I Pick Pete who know which ones Pete which one looks like is this Pete?
Let's see Demetrius a solid player who doesn't make many mistakes He has the best baby spa card collection and I don't know he just he just looked like a Pete to me is that
Yeah, his stats are not that good someone was like pick Pete you coward So I was like, okay, which one looks like the worst player
Get the fast kid which ones which one's the fast kid you all look really fast All right, let's see I want to get one of the twins and split them up and let the other twin know that they're they weren't good enough Sorry, ma'am.
All right, let's see She's Sidney and her twin sister Ashley are quite a dynamic duo on the field when they are on the same team.
That is all right I'll just watch.
All right, who's faster?
Oh They're both the same stats.
Okay, Ashley or Okay, Ashley or Sydney and are quite a dynamic duo.
All right, Ashley or Sydney.
Okay.
All right, which one?
All right, I'm right-handed.
So I'm gonna pick Ashley Also Sydney was an asshole to me at school so I
Knew a Sydney and she was an ass
So I'm only gonna pick Ashley
All right, let's see this is personal guys, this is very personal Super thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I told myself that you pick Pablo the only legal number one pick in this game.
You will be rewarded Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Next to Ashley.
Oh, is that Pete?
Wait, how are you wheelie?
Point Pete in the right direction and tell him to run.
No one will catch him and it's my wait Pete You're on the team.
Look at your stats He's so fast You're in the team Pete, you'll be the runner of the team
Thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
All right Pete's in All right, we got Kenny.
Don't worry Kenny's I saw him with the wheels and I was like that's practically cheating He literally has a car in baseball.
So like he's in that man is in the team All right, let's see
Someone said check the frog guy.
The only time Marky wears shoes is to school and church He really doesn't like him our socks either but he does like playing baseball and he's oh, but your stats bro Like this is a baseball game.
We need a run Marky I can't have you on the team if you can't run Marky.
What are you gonna do when the ball comes at you?
You gotta run All right Well shit, he's not a runner we don't having non runners on this team we have to have he hits he doesn't He doesn't need a run jokey he can hit all right He's not even for baseballs What do you mean?
He's the he's the home runner.
He doesn't even hit four.
That's what Pablo is for We don't need him.
We have Pablo You'll be sorry All right, dude with the headphones, oh shit All right, Axeman 7-eleven when when Ahmed isn't rocking out with his headphones on he's a pretty solid player Definitely a power hitter.
He has a younger brother named Amir.
Oh my god.
That's our bat That's our home run guy right there That's him he can run and bat guys, how is our pitching and fielding doesn't matter as long as we hit everything We don't have to matter about pitching or pitching and fielding guys You're in you can run you can bat guys.
I don't think my team is very well rounded, but that's okay Like I said, I'll start turn down the sound a little bit as long What he's cooked wait, but but he has four baseballs How is he cooked chat, yeah, he has four baseballs Okay, guys, we need somebody that can pitch in field.
I realized that I made a little bit of a mistake
Tony Tony's got a lot of things going for him.
The biggest of which is his arm.
It's a cannon He's a great choice for playing in the outfield.
Okay All right, we have him.
Okay, we need somebody Wait, Angela is God tier, which one's Angela What Maria locks Maria locks and lacks in baseball smart she's makes up for enthusiasm and in case didn't know Maria's favorite color is Pink.
I'm sorry.
We're looking for a we're looking for a fielder.
We got Kenny, right?
Oh, wait Is this I want to play on your team?
Oh the fielding Miss mrs. Smith with an MVP on the ball field Jacinda is certainly one of the most valuable players with good overall skill and the best swing in town She's always the top pick.
Okay.
She sounds good.
She sounds good on the field She has four baseballs guys for baseballs on both batting and fielding miss just in miss Smith is gonna fucking do this first She's gonna clutch it.
All right, we're gonna get you're in the team You're in the team.
All right, we have three more pics.
Oh Who else?
Oh my god, if you want to win, you'll pick me to be on your team.
Oh, we already have we have Kenny.
Sorry
We have Kenny.
Kenny's our pitcher.
I thought Kenny's our... What's Kenny for?
You guys are telling me Kenny has the best arm for pitching.
Like, what's Kenny for anyway?
Check Dante.
You need two?
Wait, I need two?
All right, you're in Angela.
You're in.
OneBody, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Today's my 30th birthday.
Thank you for always entertaining me and with your streams.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear OneBody.
Yeah!
All right, OneBody, since it's your birthday, do we get Angela?
Does Angela deserve to be on our team?
To be in our... the next Dodger...
Dodgers, watch out.
We're gonna head over to the Major League Baseball.
What do you say, OneBody?
Do we pick her up?
What do you say?
It's your choice.
Do you think she deserves to be a Dodger?
Sorry, the Rockets?
We don't want Dodgers to sue us either, so...
All right, OneBody, take it a little bit.
I'm gonna... I'll get back to Ashley later.
I'll get back to Ashley later.
I'll keep a spot open for her if you say yes.
We still have two more.
Oh, absolutely, get in here.
If Angela fucks up, I'm timing you out.
I'm taking...
If Angela... If Angela fucking fucks up, OneBody, you're timed out for the stream.
All right, two more, two more.
Who else?
Who should we put as our two... Oh, wait, she has a...
She has baseball clothes on.
Put her in the outfield and she'll daydream all day, guaranteed.
Loves playing shortstop and that's where she should go.
Oh, no.
We don't want that.
We don't... We don't want that, guys.
She's a daydreamer.
She has to be locked in.
Position should not matter.
If she was a real baseball fan, position shouldn't matter.
She should just be happy that she could play the game.
You're too limited right now.
You gotta be happy that you're on the field.
Frog... Bro, he doesn't run.
Frogboy doesn't run.
I can't take Frogboy.
She's a one-trick.
We cannot have one...
It is... Alright.
It is...
Showing Otani a one-trick.
Exactly.
We're making the...
I agree with Frogkid.
Okay, fine.
We'll have Frogkid.
Okay.
Alright, fine.
We'll bring him over.
Alright, he's just gonna warm the bench, guys.
Alright, last guy.
What do we get?
I mean, we have Pablo.
He can literally fucking single-handedly carry this entire team.
That's not true!
They can all run!
What do you mean?
The nerd?
What the fu... Why are you here?
We're here to make champions!
You clearly don't even wanna be here!
Oh my god.
Alright.
Endless Popcorn Kid.
Oh my god, he can run!
Wait,
he's our all-rounder!
We don't have any of those!
Alright, you're in, Dante.
Wait, what?
No, wait.
I did say no.
Get in here.
Dante, you're in!
Alright, we're ready.
The Dodgers are ready.
There you go.
Real Doki's Humongous Rocket.
Oh.
Wait.
I might have... We should not...
Oh.
I realize that name is a little...
I...
Okay.
I realize I might have...
I might have fucked up with the name a little.
But...
Okay.
Alright, let's figure this out.
Who is our pitcher again?
Okay, we're gonna put a batting order.
Pablo.
Where are you, Pablo?
Which one's Pablo?
Pablo.
Okay.
Who's the best pitcher, guys?
You guys were saying...
Angela.
Alright, Angela.
Angela, you're in.
What the fuck?
Angela.
Get over here.
You're gonna be pitching.
And then...
Pablo will be first.
Marky, I know Marky, you're really good at...
hitting those balls as well.
So if we hit it all the way here, that would be a home run.
And...
Best batter is fourth?
Okay, you're right.
Alright, there we go.
This should be it.
Frogboy is the catcher.
And then...
I don't remember who's fast, guys.
Who's fast again?
Okay.
These are all our players.
Oh my god, they're all fast.
Okay, as long as our slowest...
Okay, Jacinda.
Are you...
Who is it that hates Zeus Daydreams again?
Did I get the Daydreamer?
I didn't, right?
Okay, good.
We didn't have a Daydreamer.
Because I made sure.
Alright, let's see.
Dante and Pablo are the fastest.
Oh, Dante and Pablo are the fastest.
Oh my god, MarkyD, you get over here.
You get over here.
I don't trust you, MarkyD.
You don't run.
You don't...
Wait, hover over Pablo?
Where's Pablo?
Oh my god, Pablo.
Oh my god.
No thoughts, just Pablo.
He's getting ready.
He's locked in right now.
Oh my god.
He is my final boss.
I literally picked the best player.
Those other teams, they don't know what's coming.
Okay.
Alright, this should be good.
Center field, left field.
Alright.
Alright, Rockets, I believe in you.
Third base, first base.
This should be it.
He's got his own theme song.
I think we're ready.
Alright, we're playing against the wombats first.
This should be fine.
BBL?
Oh no.
The super duper wombats.
It's gonna be over for them.
What?
It's Backyard Baseball League, guys.
What else is this supposed to mean, guys?
It's Backyard Baseball League.
I love BBL.
Alright.
Come on, Humongous Rockets!
Do it for real, Doki!
Play ball!
Where the fuck is she?
Where the fuck is Laura?
Alright.
Alright, Pete!
Pete, all you do is love writing, Pete!
You got this!
Oh, I have to bat?
Oh shit, that's why I keep losing.
Um...
Alright.
We're gonna get...
We're gonna get this.
And then, I don't remember how...
Okay.
Okay!
It's fine!
Lock in, lock in, Pete!
Guys, I'm adjusting.
I didn't realize.
I forgot.
Oh, come on, Pete!
Pete, what are you doing?
I forgot.
This is why I was really bad at this game.
No!
Oh, Pete!
What are you doing?
What?
What are you doing, Pete?
It's okay, Kenny's gonna...
Kenny's gonna redeem us.
It's okay.
What am I doing?
What is Pete doing?
It's not my fault!
What is it?
Oh!
What are these bitches?
What?
Okay.
There's no way.
There's no way, Kenny!
Guys!
Guys, I'm figuring this out.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Okay, there's no way.
Come on, Kenny, I believe in you.
That's a ball.
That has to be a ball.
Okay, I can read it.
Okay, this is it.
I'm walking in.
That was a hit!
Kenny, how could you do this to me, Kenny?
That should have been a hit!
It's okay, Dante.
Come on, Dante.
You can't let me down.
I brought you the hot dog.
You can't...
It was the ping, guys!
It was the ping!
Yes!
Go, Dante, go!
Run!
Your heart loves it!
You love running, Dante!
Okay, I believe in Kenny.
Don't kill me.
Oh, Pablo.
Pablo!
My man!
Let's go, Pablo!
You can't disappoint me.
You're in tight.
That's right.
I'm putting it power level.
Oh, fuck.
No!
Run!
Oh, thank God.
They're stupid.
They're children.
Oh, thank God.
Children are stupid.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I put Ashley on fifth.
Okay, this is gonna...
Okay, line drive.
This is the only way we can do this.
Pablo, you got this.
Oh, come on!
Come on!
No!
Yes!
Run!
No, Ashley!
Why can't you run?
Ashley, you...
I should've got your sister!
I should've got your fucking sister!
Oh, you're terrible!
Ashley.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, we're not gonna put Ashley as fifth batter.
It's not... Oh my... No, I should've got the other sister.
I...
Things I've said to an ex.
Okay.
The left hook.
There's no way.
So it'll be like... Alright, here we go.
Alright, let's go.
What?!
Get it, Angela!
Get it!
Yes!
I knew it!
I knew I could count on you, Angela!
Oh, you're so good!
You should get a scholarship, Angela!
You should get a scholarship!
You're gonna redeem us right here!
You're gonna redeem the Rockets!
I can't believe he bunted.
Like, what kind of loser does that?
What?!
Foul!
Thank God.
Good.
Okay.
Strike.
Alright.
Okay, right hook.
Right hook right here.
There's no way.
Another strike, Angela!
Oh!
The Dodgers are watching right now, Angela.
You got this!
Alright.
Heat time.
Right here.
What?!
Kenny, please.
Kenny, no!
Alright.
We did it.
No, no.
Kenny is fine.
Kenny deserves it.
Oh my God.
We're baseballing right now.
There's no way.
Strike one.
Get out.
Get out of here.
You're so stupid.
You're children.
Alright.
Right steal.
What?!
How?!
Oh my God.
No, Kenny!
Kenny, please!
Kenny, no!
Kenny!
No!
Oh my God.
Kenny, please.
Come on.
Run.
You wanna run.
Come on.
Run.
Yeah!
You're so stupid!
That's what you write!
Get baited!
Children!
No way.
I knew it.
I knew they would run.
Kids can't...
Kids can't fucking...
They're never patient.
I know children aren't patient.
Don't catch it.
No!
They're never patient.
They can't wait.
They're just gonna be like...
If they don't...
If they...
They're just like...
What are they gonna do?
It has to be ball.
It's outside the square.
Alright, here we go.
We got this.
What if I...
That's another ball.
She's gonna let me walk.
That's right.
You don't have Angela on your team.
I do.
That has to be no ball.
What?
How?
That's so high.
That's higher than my height.
That should be a ball.
Okay.
There's no way.
You run.
She doesn't run.
I forgot you don't run.
I forgot she doesn't run.
Oh my god.
He doesn't run.
I forgot to put all my runners at the beginning.
I put all my runners in the beginning.
It's okay.
You got this.
That's a hit.
That was a hit.
What do you mean that wasn't?
I'm in.
That's right.
You blew it for the rest of the team.
I hope you feel the guilt later.
Oh my god.
There's still four more rounds.
You got headphones on.
You're not taking this seriously.
Okay.
That's okay.
Right hook.
That's alright.
Angeles.
Are you serious?
How?
What if you guys get it?
That's fine.
You're gonna move.
You wanna move, don't you?
That's my guy.
You wanna run, don't you?
You know you wanna run.
Come on.
I knew it.
Put it back.
That's right.
Yeah, get out.
Get out.
Get out of here.
That cannot be it.
There's no way that's a foul.
Why does the commenters sound like Travis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It just works.
Okay, I'll stop cheesing here.
I'm just mad.
I'm just mad right now.
I'll stop bullying the kids.
Are you serious?
How?
Ashley, please.
No, Ashley.
No!
Why is she on my team?
Why?
How do they do it?
How?
It's all...
This is the only way they'll get a point.
This is...
Goddamn children.
There's no way this AI is 97.
How could they know what I'm trying to do?
I'll do a slow ball.
They won't know.
That's... I knew it.
And I'll do a fast ball.
Okay.
Alright.
Come on.
Come on, Angela.
You can't disappoint...
He didn't even register what happened.
He didn't... Oh, we do a right hook.
And then after that...
We do a right hook.
He didn't even register in his brain what happened.
Get out.
Get out of my game.
Right now.
And we'll do another slow ball.
We'll do another slow ball.
He's gonna swing.
Yes!
Get your ass outta here.
Get your ass... I have learned how to play.
Still another one?
Did I not get...
Oh my god, it's cause he got a home run.
I forgot.
It's cause she got a fucking home run.
I was like, fireball.
This is it.
Okay, no.
We'll do right hook first.
Right hook and then we'll do fireball.
We'll do fireball as the last resort.
Alright, slow ball.
He won't expect another...
He won't expect another slow ball.
There's no way.
Come on.
Are you serious?
Pablo, please.
Pablo.
Get over here.
That's right, get back in here.
You thought you could get a second base?
Use your head.
Use your fucking head.
You stupid child.
Got so greedy and now you disappointed your team.
That's what you get.
Get outta here.
Okay, um...
Marky, I need you to get a home run.
Marky, I...
I mean...
I need you to...
What do you mean no cheese?
He ran to second base himself.
I didn't even cheese it.
Okay, that...
That was my bad.
Yes!
Go!
You're so...
Go, please!
Mark, no!
You're so slow!
Fraud!
Why are you so slow?
Why?
I don't understand.
Oh my god.
Why?
That's okay.
We need a home run.
We just need one point.
Oh, wait, no!
No, no, come on, get over there!
Yes!
You're so fast!
I knew it!
You're so fast.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Kenny, you got this, Kenny.
Alright, Kenny.
First game of the season.
First game of... Oh, shit.
We were just testing it out.
First game... This is the first game of the season, guys.
We need the win.
We need a win, guys.
The moment we get our first win, it's over for the entire season.
We know we can get this.
The wombats...
The wombats are the best team of the league right now.
The moment we get this first win, the rest of the team will be so easy.
Okay, there we go.
Go, go!
Go, you're so fast!
Kenny, I swear to god, use your wheels!
Use your wheels!
Yes, Kenny!
Oh my god, bases are going to be loaded soon.
Who is it?
Alright, Dante.
Come on, Dante.
I need you to do this for the rest of the boys.
Dante.
This is... Oh, shit.
Okay, I wanted to swap to open.
Alright.
Come on, Dante.
We need that home run.
Dante, that's okay.
We can make one mistake, Dante.
You got the burger in you.
Come on.
No!
Okay, it's okay, Dante.
If you get out, we have Pablo.
We don't matter, Dante.
We just need Pablo.
Okay, wait.
Okay,
we gotta do square.
We gotta get squared.
Come on, Pablo.
That has to be ball.
Thank god.
Okay, come on.
Come on, Pablo.
It's okay, if Dante fucks up, we have Pablo as our backup.
God!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
This is why we got Pablo in.
Come on.
Pablo.
I can't help it.
I just wanna swing.
Come on, Pablo.
Baseball is in your blood, Pablo.
You already have a baseball scholarship.
And you're like...
What?
Come on, Pablo.
You already have a baseball scholarship.
And you haven't even gone to middle school yet.
This is it!
Go, Pablo!
Yes!
The first one today.
Okay, that's...
Let's go.
Let's go, Pablo!
You got us the score we needed.
Alright, Ashley.
I know you can't run.
So I'm just gonna...
We're gonna make sure that your ball will not hit.
That can't be...
That's a strike?
That's barely in there.
There's no way.
What?
That's barely in the...
That's not in the square.
There!
Okay, come on.
Yes!
Kenny!
You had wheels!
No, Ashley!
This is your fault, Ashley!
We're benching, Ashley.
Kenny.
You're literally in a car, Kenny.
Kenny, why?
Why, Kenny?
You're literally...
I'm angry.
I'm fucking angry.
Now we...
That's all that was.
Oh my god.
Ashley was the worst mistake I ever made.
Ashley was actually the worst...
The worst mistake I ever made.
But Angela's gonna...
Angela...
Has been doing so well for us.
Ball?
How is mine a ball?
Okay.
Here we go.
This should be fine.
Get out!
Get out of my game!
You don't even have personality or characteristics.
You're all just NPCs against my children.
Alright, let's go.
Okay, we're gonna put slow-mo.
Slow-mo will work.
Nice.
It was so slow.
She can't see more than five frames.
You need both twins.
But I didn't want both twins.
I didn't realize that they get depressed if it wasn't both twins.
I thought I could get away with one twin.
Okay, right hook.
Is it?
No, Angela will never rest.
Angela, you rest when I tell you, Angela.
You're literally carrying the entire team on your shoulders right now.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We have big freeze.
We're gonna use extra slow-mo.
We're gonna use big freeze.
Actually, no.
We gotta left hook first.
He doesn't know.
You punted?
Oh my god.
You're both so fucking slow.
Oh, how?
How?
Who told me to get the frog boy?
Oh my god.
Frog boy was a mistake.
It was...
It was a mistake.
She's a disappointment to the entire team.
What?
I was like, what's going on?
What are you trying to steal?
I'm sorry.
I got brain lag.
There.
My god.
I got brain lag right there when she's like trying to steal.
I was like, what do you mean?
Okay.
Alright, Josinda.
This is it.
Okay, wait.
Is Josinda fast?
I'm gonna do this.
I'm gonna bunt it.
There's no way.
What?
Okay.
Oh, done.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, great hitter?
Okay, we'll do this then.
I didn't realize she's a great hitter.
I already forgot.
I forgot all their stats.
Oh, god.
Great hitter, my fucking ass.
Josinda, you're so slow.
Josinda!
Great hitter, my fucking ass.
A great what?
What do you mean?
You hit a bad...
Oh, it's my fault.
It's my...
Okay.
Are you fast?
I don't remember.
There's too many kids on my team.
It's hard to keep track.
Guys, there's too many children on my team.
I can't remember.
I can't remember who's who.
God damn it, Angela.
Please.
I'm surprised I couldn't even remember my children's names.
There's so many of you.
Okay, we got a foul.
We get a foul.
That's fine.
Come on, Angela.
Come on.
I will never swap you out of you.
No!
One more foul.
We can do one more.
Angela, lock the fuck in.
We need one.
Angela, please.
Oh, nice, Angela!
Go!
Go, Angela!
Oh, no!
It's so high in the air!
Angela, you're so slow, Angela!
Oh!
You got this!
Get your slow ass around the base, Angela!
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Get your slow ass across.
It's so good.
That's so good.
Angela!
Alright, here we go.
We take those.
Oh, God.
Come on, Achmed.
We need you to do this for Angela.
She's so slow.
The fuck is that?
Come on, lock in.
Lock in.
This has to be ball.
That has to be ball.
That was so out of there.
Come on, let me walk.
Let me walk.
Oh, that's a walk right there.
Get my walk across!
Wait, he gets another ball?
Come on.
Oh, God.
Damn it.
Give me another ball.
No!
Achmed!
Oh, God.
Get your headphones off.
You can't hear anything.
Achmed, take those off.
Oh, my God.
Why did you...
I don't know.
I don't know the FPS.
I don't know the...
Oh, no.
No, you're so...
No, you're so slow.
You're so...
You're so slow.
I don't know when I need to hit.
I can't tell.
I can't tell the frames of when I'm supposed to hit the ball.
I...
I don't know the frames per second when I'm supposed to click it.
What is the hitbox?
He's better at bunting.
Let's bunt two carries at this point.
Here we go.
How do you fuck up bunting?
How do you...
How do you fuck it up?
How do you fuck up bunting?
Alright.
Bro, I'm scared.
How do you...
How does he fuck up bunting?
I don't understand.
This is...
I don't...
I don't... Oh, my God.
After everything Angela did.
After...
Why'd you bunt?
Cause chat told me to bunt.
Angela, I need you.
Angela, you can do this.
Go all the way to the end, Angela.
Oh, my God.
Get those poor fools out.
Full strikeout, no hits.
Angela will swap until I tell her.
She'll get swapped when I tell her to get swapped.
She has one more in her, guys.
She has one more in her.
She has one more.
Use all of that.
That's right.
What?
Don't worry.
She'll pitch until...
Angela, you got this.
Okay, maybe a timeout.
Maybe a timeout.
Wait, how do I swap her?
Okay, Angela, you got it.
We're gonna put you...
Alright, we got...
Oh, my God, Mark.
I can't.
No, wait.
She's slow?
Where do we put her?
And he's my other only pitcher.
Where the fuck do we put her?
Okay, we're gonna put you...
Oh, you're also slow.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
This is it.
This should be fine.
These are all fast people.
Oh, you're right.
We put her as a catcher.
You're right.
But then he's also... MarkyD is also slow.
They're both slow.
What the fuck do I do?
Okay, that's fine.
Go back in.
Alright.
Alright, Kenny, I believe in you.
Get that big freeze in there.
Yeah!
Get out!
Get out of here.
I have the best pitchers.
I have the best pitchers in this team.
Not bad or dope, but it's not me.
It's my children's fault.
What?
Oh my god, Ashley.
Please, Ashley.
That's fucking right.
Get out!
Trying to steal just because my children can't fucking hit balls?
Just...
That's fucking...
Okay, we're not doing that again.
We're not...
We're not doing that again.
Just because my kids can't hit a ball, you think you can steal a base from me?
Alright.
Guys, I'm not...
I'm not a dance mom, guys.
Get out of here.
Get that right hook in there.
Get out!
Get out of my game!
We are the worst batting team, but we can sure pitch.
Oh my god, this is so intense.
This is so intense.
This is one game.
This is game one.
Oh my god, my adrenaline is so high right now.
This is even better than Koishin.
This is...
Oh my god.
I love baseball.
Oh my god, we have the power hitters on now.
We got the power hitters in.
This is it, Pete.
Oh, Pete.
Pete, let's go, Pete!
Go!
I'm bunting.
I'm fucking bunting.
I don't care.
Okay, we're not bunting anymore.
That has to be a ball.
That's a strike?
Kenny, please.
Oh, no.
Kenny, no.
Toki, please.
How did I miss a bunt?
I thought...
I thought I could...
I thought I was bunting.
Oh my god.
I swear.
I thought I hit bunt.
I swear to god.
Dante, please.
Please.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god.
What's the speed?
Okay, I need to not be early.
I need to not be early.
Come on, Dante.
Yes!
Power!
Oh my god, power.
We're putting it all in on power.
That has to be a ball.
This coach...
I don't...
I don't understand.
We have more juice.
We're gonna get...
We're gonna lock it up.
Are you serious?
I thought...
Oh my god.
Why
can't my children...
Why can't my children do the same thing?
I don't understand.
No, we can do this.
Please.
We can do this, guys.
It's not me.
I swear.
Time out.
Angela, get your ass back in here.
Angela.
Angela, where are you?
Angela, we need you in here.
We need you in here.
There we go.
This is it.
Alright, back in it.
Oh my god.
Get in.
Get that juice in.
Alright.
Here we go.
Angela, you've never disappointed me.
We're benching Kenny after that.
We're benching Kenny.
Kenny's back in the bench.
Oh my god.
Good job.
Good job, Angela.
I knew I could always count on you.
I knew it.
Come on.
What?
Foul.
Nice.
Another foul.
That's good.
Heat.
Good job, Angela.
You're my girl.
You're my fucking girl.
You've never disappointed me.
You don't disappoint the coach.
And a strike.
Get your ass out of here.
Nancy.
Get out.
Alright.
Mickey O'Connor.
You have zero personality.
You're just an NPC in this lobby.
Alright.
Oh, and we have more juice.
That's good.
Go, Angela.
Go.
Do another left hook.
Yes.
Foul.
Alright.
Angela's carrying this team.
She's putting her entire team up there.
Another.
No, there's no way.
That's a foul.
There's no way.
I knew it.
I fucking knew that's a foul.
Oh my god.
Our entire team might be fucked in terms of batting.
Not because of me, though, by the way, guys.
Get out.
Get out, Mickey O'Connor.
Don't keep experiencing how it feels to be a mess.
It's not me.
I swear to god.
Come on.
Zigzag.
It's not me.
I'm not the problem.
I don't know the hitbox and the speed.
What?
Angela, get over here.
Get out.
Get out, Angela.
You got it, girl.
You are the best pitcher in the fucking world.
Oh my god.
We need one.
It's one point.
It's one.
Come on, Pablo.
You are my only hope, Pablo.
Where's the auto?
Where's the auto batting?
Where is it?
I need one.
I literally need...
Please.
Please, Pablo.
What kind of pitcher is she?
Go, Pablo.
Go.
I don't understand.
Ashley, go fucking run.
Just run as fast as you...
I don't understand.
Pablo, how?
Did I not select...
I didn't select power.
I didn't even realize I didn't select power.
I thought he was already on power.
I was so hyped for him.
I...
Oh, no.
You're so slow.
No!
I thought...
I thought he was on power.
Oh my god, Angela.
This is it.
Does Angela do well on power?
I can't remember.
Guys.
Angela, this is it.
All in.
All on you.
All on you, Angela.
It's okay.
It's okay, Angela.
Angela, it's all on you.
Angela.
It's all on you.
We just gotta hit one hit.
Okay.
Angela, it's now or never, Angela.
Angela, come on.
How?
Are you serious?
Angela, please.
Please, this is it.
This is your character arc.
Angela, please.
No, not another foul.
We have one more.
There's no pressure, Angela.
There's no pressure.
No!
It's okay.
Guys, team.
Team.
It's okay.
It's one game.
Rockets.
Rockets, this is our character arc.
We...
We might have lost the first game.
Rockets, don't...
Don't let this loss affect you.
This is one game.
Rockets.
It's okay.
They were the hardest team in this entire lineup.
We still have the whole season ahead of us.
It's okay.
Like, we're not even last.
We're fifth place.
It's okay.
We have the entire season.
Rockets.
Guys.
Alright, group pep talk here.
Guys, it's not me.
Good pep talk.
Look.
We all know who the MVP is here.
And it's goddamn Angela.
Angela has put our entire team on her fucking backs.
And like, we got...
Look.
Look, guys.
The moment I realized what the...
What the hitbox and the frames and the projectile speed of the baseball is.
It's all over, team.
I just haven't downloaded the projectile speed yet.
The moment I figure out what the projectile speed of the baseball is.
The moment I figure out what the projectile speed is.
It's so over.
It's...
It's gonna...
We're gonna do it.
I just need to know the projectile speed of this game.
Alright, guys.
This is it.
Come on, Rockets.
The crazy Giants.
Oh, my God.
It's the Giants.
Pablo is gonna leave.
But Pablo...
Pablo fucked up.
It's not because I fucked up.
Not me.
This is it.
Alright.
This is where we're gonna redeem ourselves.
New York Football Giants.
Do you need medical attention, Dookie?
Especially if the joke is that hard.
Are you saying thank you for the super chat thing?
Oh, guys.
We're gonna...
This is our character arc.
We lose our first game, and then we're gonna fucking register everything.
This is it.
Oh, my God.
I figured...
I'm figuring out the speed, guys.
I'm figuring out the speed right now.
Oh, come on!
Come on!
Power.
Come on.
What is the projectile speed?
Yes!
Let's go!
Don't catch it!
No!
I can't do...
Kenny, please.
Kenny, yes!
Get that out there!
No!
Kenny!
At least I'm hitting it.
Guys, I'm hitting the ball.
Guys, I'm hitting the ball now.
Okay.
The ball is getting hit.
Oh, my God.
Oh, thank God.
The ball is getting hit.
Okay,
Pablo.
This is it, Pablo.
I'm hitting the ball.
They're getting caught.
But I'm hitting the ball, though.
I'm hitting it.
This is it.
Come on, Pablo.
That had to be a ball.
We're in power.
This is it.
We're doing it.
There's no way.
I was gonna say, there's no way.
Come on.
Come on, Pablo.
Don't do this to me.
Ball three.
One more ball, Pablo.
One more ball.
We're gonna get the easiest walk of our lives, Pablo.
Swing!
Go, Pablo!
Pablo, no!
Pablo!
Oh,
my God, Pablo.
I'm hitting the ball.
I'm hitting it.
He hit the ball.
I thought you guys said Pablo was the juice.
I thought you said Pablo was the blood.
When baseball was in his blood.
I'm not even throwing anymore.
This is all Pablo.
That's ball, Angela.
What happened?
It's first inning.
Oh, my God.
Why can't my children do this?
Oh, Kenny.
Why?
Why, Kenny?
No!
Move your ass.
Move.
Run.
I need this.
Be quiet.
I couldn't.
I couldn't trick the AI.
What happened?
What happened, Angela?
What?
Angela, what happened?
Angela!
At least
get him out.
Oh, thank God.
How is this team even better?
How is this team better?
This team is not bad.
No!
We still have so many innings left, guys.
This is...
This is our character art.
This is our character art, guys.
How can they analyze Angela?
Angela, please.
You are literally the chosen one, Angela.
Get out.
Yes!
We need one more.
We got Molly out.
Just one more.
One more, guys.
Oh, my God.
How do they do this?
Who is their coach?
How are they hitting their balls?
I don't know.
Who is their coach?
How did you get my zigzag?
Get out.
Just get out.
He is coaching.
Get out.
No, it's not falling apart.
We can redeem ourselves.
We got him.
They are all out.
We are hitting the ball now, guys.
We are hitting the ball.
Guys, we are hitting their ball.
We are figuring it out.
What do you mean?
Your team had a coach.
It has to be ball.
What?
Oh, my God.
That did not look like...
It's so high.
It's higher than my face.
Okay.
Come on.
There is no way.
Yes.
Thank God, Ashley.
Thank God.
Oh, my God, Ashley.
Okay.
We got this.
You are the slowest...
runner out there.
We got this.
Oh, come on.
Yes.
Go, Ashley.
Go.
Oh, my God.
You are so slow.
Go.
Oh, my God.
We are okay.
Nice hit.
Oh, my God.
Angela.
We are going in on the power, Angela.
Angela, this is it.
You got this.
Remember what you trained for.
It's okay.
It's okay, Angela.
We all make mistakes, Angela.
It's okay.
That's all right.
We all make mistakes.
It's okay, Angela.
You are just a thrower.
You are just a pitcher.
You are not meant to bat.
And that's okay, sweetie.
Oh, my God, Achmed.
Okay, Achmed.
This is going to be a little awful.
Achmed, we had not been doing well with you.
Achmed.
Oh, my God, Achmed.
I don't know what to do with you.
I don't know what to do with you, Achmed.
Just swing.
Achmed, just lock in.
I need you to lock in.
That's all I need you to...
Oh, my God, I'm just going to do a butt.
Achmed, just lock in.
That's all I want.
Achmed, just...
Achmed, I just...
Oh, my God, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's...
I heard somebody say butt.
And I was like, alright, I'm going to do it.
I'll never butt again.
I'm never going to butt again.
Alright, Marky, please.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, come on.
Oh, my God.
Let's go, Ashley.
Go, Ashley, go.
Just run for your life.
Let's go, Ashley.
Let's fucking go.
He did it.
He fucking did it.
Oh, my God.
Marky, you actually...
Are you mad, man?
Are you fucking mad, man?
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, go, go, go, go, go.
As fast as you can.
Go.
There's no way she can throw that far and you fucking know it.
Get that second point in.
Yeah, do you know what?
Let's go, let's go.
This might be the craziest shit I've ever done.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
Kenny, come on.
Kenny, we're making...
The arc is now...
Our baseball arc is right here.
I can't believe it.
It's time to fucking believe.
That's okay.
All right, that's fine.
That's so fine.
Come on, Kenny.
That has to be a ball.
Thank God, that's a ball.
Absolute cinema.
The redemption arc right here.
Oh, come on.
Was I too...
Was I too slow?
Kenny, please.
Kenny, I need you to hit one ball.
That has to be a ball.
Thank God, okay.
That's too late.
Okay.
Come on.
Yes!
No!
One ball.
Just one hit, Kenny.
That's all I need.
No!
Kenny!
Oh, I just need you to hit one.
It's okay, we're ahead.
We're ahead, guys.
We're ahead.
Barely, but we're ahead.
Oh my God.
Holy shit.
Okay, Zigzag, come on, Angela.
We're literally...
We're literally ahead by one.
This is the first time we've ever been ahead, chat.
Dragons, this is literally the first game that we've been ahead.
Gotta retire Pablo.
This is 15th year in the league.
Thank you for the super chat, Laura.
Thank you.
How?
Kenny, please.
Get in there.
I'm gonna trick the AI.
That's fucking right.
Get out.
I'm desperate.
Get over here.
Okay.
Alright.
Get out.
Get the fuck out of my game.
Get out of my game.
It worked, though.
Guys.
Let my girl...
If they get tired...
Get out of my game.
Who hurt you?
The entire Major League Baseball.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congratulations on your position.
I can tell from your performance...
That you're on to do great things.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We got tired of them.
Get out.
We tired them out.
We win.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She's holding up the entire team.
And her coach on her back.
There you go.
Thank God.
Another foul.
She's in a game made for toddlers.
That's my streamer.
What?
How is it so good?
Oh my God.
She's slow.
No.
Don't.
Come on.
You know you want to run.
Get out.
Come on.
Run.
You know you want to run.
She doesn't want to run.
Thank you.
She refuses to run.
He's going to make this entire league.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She saw what I did to the other kid.
What do you mean?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Her coach is streaming.
Stay.
Are you serious?
Dante, come on.
Nice.
That's fucking right.
Get out.
Come on.
Run.
You know you want to run.
Come on.
Run.
She's just staying there.
She's not running.
I don't understand.
Why is she running?
She knows.
They're learning.
Come on.
Run.
You fucking coward.
I don't understand.
I don't understand why she's not running.
This is 1997.
How are they getting smarter?
Why aren't you running?
That was so in.
I know, right?
Ramsey, thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
How?
Get out.
I can say for certain.
I wish Doki was my coach.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Thank god.
We're still in the lead.
Still in the lead, guys.
Oh my god.
Dante, please.
Guys, I know how to...
I know how to hit now.
I know how to bat.
I figured it out.
I figured it out now.
This is it.
This time.
There has to be a ball.
There's no one.
Okay.
I'm not gonna bunt.
That time I bunted.
It was a mistake.
This is it.
That's it.
Go.
It's not gonna be a mistake.
Dante, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Oh my god.
We're doing it.
Run for me, boy.
Run.
Oh my god, Pablo.
This is it.
Pablo, if you get a home run, we get two bases.
Pablo, please.
Pablo, if Dante can do this, so can you, Pablo.
This is it.
Pablo.
Pablo, please.
For the love of...
Pablo.
What happened?
What happened to you?
What?
They all told me you were a prodigy.
Everybody told me you were a fucking prodigy.
Fucking prodigy.
Were they all lying?
Ashley did more than you.
Ashley.
Fucking motherfucking Ashley.
He is your judgment.
Ashley did more.
Ashley picking up his slack.
Oh my god.
Has to be a ball.
That's a strike?
Oh my god.
Ashley popped off.
I don't understand.
How does...
How does fucking Ashley...
No, no, no, no.
Ashley, no, no!
Jacinda, why?
Why, Jacinda?
Why?
I didn't think you were gonna...
It's okay, we're ahead.
We're ahead.
It's okay.
Guys, no.
It's not over.
We're ahead.
We're ahead right now.
Angela's ready.
Angela's so ready now.
Pablo got paid off.
Pablo's playing against the team.
There's no other way.
I refuse to believe...
I refuse to believe Pablo...
Pablo was like a person anymore.
There's no way.
The story of Doki's legacy in baseball is having so many twists and turns.
Marie, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Pablo must have got bought out.
There's no way that fucking...
I...
Okay.
Come on.
Get out.
You think you can fool Angela?
You think you can fool her?
Angela's coming in clutch.
He's a rat for fucking the Giants.
He's a rat for the Giants.
I refuse to believe.
I refuse to believe he's like...
Oh my god, Angela, do this again.
Angela, do this again.
That's right.
Get out.
Get your ass out of here.
She is a goddamn prodigy.
Out.
Let's go.
Easy.
A poor workman blames his tools.
Gordon Freeman, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Angela, you are doing it.
Pablo Sanchez must be holding up for a large contract.
Carla, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Pablo Sanchez?
Who the fuck is he?
Everything Pablo has done has been...
has been nothing.
He has done nothing for this team.
Alright, we're gonna put open right here.
Come on, Angela.
That's another ball.
Good.
Power?
Alright, Angela.
This must have been out Charlie Brown.
That has to be another ball.
One more.
Give me a walker for Angela.
Oh, she's...
Let's go.
Let's go, Angela.
Let's fucking go, Angela.
Let's go.
let's go.
Pablo Caneve.
You're a pitcher and a batter.
Angela, let's go.
Okay, Akhmed, okay.
Don't fuck this up for her.
Don't fuck this up for Angela, Akhmed.
I swear to God, that's all I ask.
Do not fuck this up for her.
That has to be a ball.
That has to be, yeah.
Come on, Angela, the true MC.
No, that's a foul.
Hey, batter, batter, batter.
Come on.
Come on, Akhmed.
Don't fuck this up for Angela.
Akhmed, please!
Please, Akhmed.
Don't fuck this up for her.
Akhmed.
Again.
I need you to hit one.
One ball.
Oh my God.
Okay, Marky.
Marky boy.
You are one of the slowest runners, so we're gonna...
Alright.
That's a ball.
Okay, Mark.
Okay, fucking Marky Mark.
Marky Mark, remember what you've done before, Marky Mark.
Oh, no.
No, goodbye.
Nerdy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, wish Daniel and me a happy first wedding anniversary.
This is one of his favorite games.
He asked Daniel how to fucking win.
But happy anniversary.
Nerdy.
Thank you.
Frog boy was not locked in.
He was not.
How did he win?
Oh, no.
Run!
Stay, stay, stay, stay.
You're not fucking getting there.
You're not.
Angela, you had to stay.
You're not getting over there.
I saw how slow she was running.
I knew it was over.
I knew it was over with her running.
Okay, Kenny, please.
You haven't zeroed out for two today.
But this is the moment.
How?
Kenny, that...
Kenny, how?
Kenny.
Okay, that's it.
Kenny!
Kenny, this is...
Zero out of three.
Kenny.
You had...
You had one job, Oh my god, do we have juice?
Guys, we need juice here.
Guys, bring in the juice.
Where's the juice?
Alright, that's fine.
Okay.
Where's Kenny?
Can he get in here?
We need you here.
I need you here.
And then, this is fine.
Okay.
Alright, Kenny.
Oh my god.
Kenny, please.
Do not fuck this up for me.
Kenny, I can't.
Oh my god.
They're just... Baseball is a serious sport.
It doesn't matter if they're children.
It doesn't matter if they're kids.
This is all or nothing right now for these children.
If they don't make it out of the BPL, If they don't make it out of the BPL, they'll never get anywhere in life.
They gotta learn.
There's no crying in baseball.
It's a backyard baseball league.
It's serious.
It's so serious.
It's the champion of the fucking universe.
It's literally the champion of the fucking universe, guys.
The fuck is elevator?
What the fuck is elevator?
That did nothing.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
We have two.
One more.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Kenny, please.
For the love of god.
Strike one.
Nice.
Okay.
That's good.
Lock in.
Lock in, Kenny.
You're the backup.
I need you.
Oh my god.
Kenny, please!
Pick it up.
Come on.
Run!
Run, you fucker!
I don't wanna run.
You coward.
Oh my god.
Dante, why did you run that way?
Get out.
It's hilarious.
We're two ahead.
This is good.
I didn't cheese because it didn't work.
Is it really cheesing if it didn't work?
Chat, is it really?
Is it really cheesing?
Oh my god.
This is so hard.
Baseball is fucking serious business, chat.
Baseball is so fucking serious.
Come
on!
That was so fast.
What?
How did I not hit?
That was a hit.
That was such a hit.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
We'll do a square.
We're gonna get squared.
It has to be.
It has to be a ball.
That was literally outside the fucking square.
Come on.
That's it.
That's another foul?
Dante, please.
Dante, you were able to hit every ball.
Today will be the first time you miss.
Oh!
Dante!
Pablo, I don't...
I have zero hope for you, Pablo.
Pablo, I don't even...
Pablo, I...
I just have zero hope for you.
I don't know what the fuck you're gonna be doing today.
I don't know.
Oh, that was...
Bro, I can't even tell that was a strike.
Pablo is a sellout.
Oh, come on.
Pablo, it was paid off.
I was lied to.
Everyone was like, Pablo's clutch.
Pablo's so fucking clutch.
Pablo...
Pablo, please.
Oh, Pablo!
Oh my god, Pablo, no, no, no!
Oh, fucking life!
That was the worst hit ever, but for the first time in your life...
That was the worst hit I ever saw, but that's fine.
That was literally the worst hit I've ever saw in my life.
But that's fine.
Oh my god, Ashley, please.
You're so slow, Ashley.
No, it's okay, but Pablo got here.
Pablo got there.
It's fine.
You sacrificed yourself for Pablo, Ashley.
Alright.
I'm gonna do a line drive.
I'm gonna do a line drive, and I'm gonna close right here.
Now, that is...
That had to be a ball.
That was, like, way too low.
Power?
Okay, I'm gonna do power!
Oh!
Wait!
Oh my god, you're so slow!
Please!
You got this!
Josinda, please!
Josinda!
Holy shit!
I should've just made him run to boom.
I should've just...
Angela, this is it, Angela!
You never...
She's so slow.
She's actually so fucking slow.
Holy shit, watching Josinda.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that has to be a foul.
Okay.
Angela, please, please.
We need you to get us up one point.
That's all I want.
Angela!
Angela, go!
Oh my god, Josinda!
It's been 20 years, we're not getting it!
Josinda, please!
Why are you so slow?
Oh my god.
Why is...
Josinda so slow?
How is she...
like this?
How is she like this?
Pablo almost made it.
I didn't realize he wasn't running!
I thought he would run!
He didn't!
He didn't run!
Time out!
Angela, get back in here.
Angela, get back in there.
Get back in there.
Oh my god.
Why did he stand there?
Sometimes they auto-run, but he didn't!
He didn't auto-run!
He didn't automatic run!
I don't understand!
Let's go!
Go, Angela, you're my only hope in this fucking world!
He doesn't understand English.
I'm just joking.
I'm desperate.
I'm so desperate.
Oh, that's right!
Get your ass out here!
Alright, get Kenny back in.
Okay, alright.
Okay.
Alright, get back Kenny in there.
I got what I needed.
I got...
Get him back in here.
Alright, Kenny.
Now it's your turn.
Get out!
Child!
Oh my god.
That's a ball!
Kenny, stop doing a ball!
Kenny!
I need you to stop doing balls!
Oh my god, Kenny!
Oh, Kenny!
Kenny!
Why?
Kenny, I swapped you out one time!
No way!
No fucking way!
Kenny!
Kenny, please!
Oh my god.
There's no way.
Oh my god, that's why he's not the ace.
Kenny!
Oh my god.
If I could...
If I could, I would fucking bring Angela back.
I would fucking bring Angela back.
Oh my god, I would bring her back if I could, chat.
She refuses to get back in the field because for some reason her arm is tired.
She doesn't know this is life or death right now.
She doesn't fucking know right now that it's life or death, that this is money on the line.
Like...
There's no way.
Oh, thank god.
At least you did something.
At least you fucking did something.
Kenny, I'm so proud of you.
Well, I should thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm with the Chicago White Sox after setting the record for most losses ever.
No one wants to be our next manager.
Would you be...
What are you trying to say?
What are you trying to say, Washer?
I am in the lead right now.
I'm gonna win my first game.
This is it.
Come on.
Come on, get this court through.
Yes!
Thank you for the super chat, Washer.
Thank you.
Alright.
Alright, this is it.
This is it.
Oh my god.
One...
One more round.
Oh my god, it's Achmed.
I need to pause myself real quick.
Okay.
Okay, Achmed.
Achmed, please.
You're 0- You're 0-2 right now.
Come on.
Okay, ball.
Come on, Achmed.
This is your one time in your entire life.
This is...
Ach- Oh!
Oh my god!
Achmed!
Oh, you mad lad!
Oh my god, Achmed!
She dropped the fumble!
Fumble!
Holy shit!
The fucking fumble!
Another fumble!
Okay.
It's fine.
We got another fumble.
That's fine.
We got double fumbles.
Okay, Achmed.
That's good.
We got double fumbles.
Oh, come on.
Come on, Pete!
Pete, come on!
Come on, Pete.
Come on.
Oh, Pete.
Please.
You're so fast.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Oh god, nice.
Oh, thank god.
Oh my- Kenny, I swear.
Kenny, you're 0-3.
Kenny.
Kenny, you're 0-3, Kenny.
Kenny, you're fucking 0-3, Kenny.
I- Kenny, I need you to lock it in, Kenny.
Oh my god.
Kenny, please.
Please.
I need you to lock in.
Like, I- I need you to lock in, Kenny, for the love of god.
That has to be a ball.
Okay.
Come on.
Kenny.
Kenny, you have the wheels.
You literally have wheels, Kenny.
Like.
Oh god.
No, don't catch the ball.
No, kennyyyyyyyyy!
KENNNYYYYYYYYYYYY!
I- I- Kenny.
I- Kenny.
I- They auto-run!
They auto-run!
I couldn't stop them!
I couldn't stop them I actually couldn't.
Oh my god, get out.
Kenny, I need you to get out of my fucking game right now.
I couldn't stop them from running.
I swear to God.
Oh my god, there's no way.
There's no way.
Get juiced up.
Get juiced up, Angela.
We need you to be so fucking juiced.
No, Dante, please.
Come on.
Run.
Get out.
Yeah, I'm desperate.
I need my win for the children.
Kenny's a fucking win trader.
I swear to God.
I won't even be surprised.
I won't even be surprised if he's a win trader.
Guys, my children need to win.
I don't care if I'm cheesing it.
Guys, my children... after everything Angela's been through, you cannot... you cannot say I'm cheesing.
Angela has been through so much.
She has tried her fucking ass to carry the team.
Angela has been through so fucking much.
She deserves this.
She deserves this fucking win.
Get out.
She gave her arm for this fucking team, chat.
Are you fucking serious?
Kenny, please.
And yeah, you want to run.
Don't you want to run?
Run.
Run right now.
Run your fucking ass right now.
Run.
You know you want to run.
Come on.
Run.
I need this out.
Come on.
Oh, he's gonna have the ball now too.
You know you want to run.
Come on.
Where is he gonna throw it?
He's gonna flinch.
I believe in him flinching.
He's gonna flinch right now.
He's gonna... He does.
Come on.
Run, you fool.
God damn it.
God fucking damn it.
He refuses to run.
What do I do?
He fucking refuses to run.
Are you serious?
What?
How is this?
What is this character rank?
A friend has to help untangle the pitcher's arm.
How is that allowed?
I don't understand.
How is she allowed to do that?
There's no way.
Angela, Angela, this is... Angela, please.
Yes, Angela!
Let's go!
After everything we've been through.
Angela, we did it.
Angela.
Angela, let's fucking go.
I knew it.
Whoever that was that told me to get Angela.
What is your name?
Bombatti?
Bombatti, your pick was the clutchest pick I've ever seen.
Bombatti.
You know Bombatti.
You know what, Bombatti?
You're getting mod.
Where are you?
I'm fucking modding you.
Bombatti fucking gave me... Who the fuck told me Pablo?
Whoever told me Pablo, if I remember your name, I'm fucking timing you out.
Oh my god.
You got promoted, Bombatti.
Happy birthday.
Angela was the most clutchest pick I've ever had.
I can't believe it.
You're mod for a day.
I'll give you mod for a day.
You'll go be fucking happy birthday.
You get to be mod for a fucking day.
Where is he?
Get him up here.
Where are you, Bombatti?
Angela has been the most...
Okay, look.
Wombats was literally the best team.
They won another game chat.
Wombats was literally the best team in this entire run.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I'm done.
I'm too stressed out.
My god.
I'm way too stressed out right now.
Oh, happy birthday, Bombatti.
You get to be...
You get to be mod for a day.
Congratulations.
I'm gonna remember to take mod for a day.
Congratulations, Bombatti.
You gave me the best pick of my life there.
Holy shit.
That was so... I'm done.
I won my game.
That was my character arc right there.
Oh my god.
We have another stream anyway.
Holy shit.
That was my character arc for the day.
Oh my god, Angela.
Thank god, Angela did it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, my goat.
Angela, my fucking goat.
You literally had the entire team on your back and brought us to the finish line.
I'm so proud of my girl.
I'm so proud of her.
Oh my god.
If it wasn't for her, I don't know what I'll do.
Holy shit.
She was a hero.
She was actually a hero throughout that run.
That was so intense.
My adrenaline is pumping so hard from those games, guys.
Like, actually, I've never felt so much adrenaline right now from those two games.
I don't know about you guys.
I don't know if your adrenaline is like so fucking high from those two games, but that was intense.
That fucking crazy bunt in the end.
This was the most hype I've seen you all.
Bro, it was so intense.
It was so intense and everything, guys.
Like, oh my god.
That was so fun.
I had a lot of fun playing chat, and I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching today.
We do have a Goodnight Dragoon stream in two hours, so I'm saving most of my yapping over there, but I hope you guys had a great time watching me today.
I'm gonna be showing a lot of like sneak peeks for future projects tomorrow in the... not tomorrow, today.
Tonight in the Goodnight Dragoons, so stick around for the Goodnight Dragoon stream to see what I'm... what's been cooking and behind the scenes.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna rest now.
I need to calm down.
I need...
I need to fucking calm down.
That was so fun, though.
I... oh my god.
The fucking batting was...
oh my god.
What is that fucking projectile speed?
What is the... what do you mean I don't hit it?
Why?
Pablo, I thought you were the chosen one.
I thought baseball was in your fucking blood, but you know who carried?
Goddamn Angela.
God, Angela got like doubles.
She got... she didn't get a hard one, but at least she didn't get a fucking weak-ass hit.
And also Kenny.
Kenny and Pablo, my two star... my two supposed star players, ended up throwing so hard.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing, and if you stay up for me, stay up a little longer because I'm gonna have another stream tonight.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!